der linguist noam chomsky ist ein
brillanter kopf und hat mit der
begründung der sogenannten universal
grammatik die sprachwissenschaft
revolutioniert bekannt ist tomoski aber
auch als ein äußerst scharfzüngiger
kritiker der us-amerikanischen außen und
wirtschaftspolitik
zudem spricht chomsky längst nicht mehr
von demokraten und republikanern für ihn
sind beide vertreter einer einzigen
partei der business party aber fleisch
ist in die usa geflogen und hat dort nun
dzemski getroffen ein gespräch über ein
faszinierendes land im widerspruch
new england und sein zentrum die stadt
boston gelten als wiege der us
amerikanischen kultur religiöse
puritaner waren es die anfangs des 17ten
jahrhunderts aus der alten in die neue
welt übersiedelten
sie gründeten zeitung schulen und 1636
die erste universität des landes die
harvard university in cambridge
heute gehört sie zu den renommiertesten
ausbildungsstätten weltweit
nur einige straßen weiter liegen die
gebäude des des massachusetts institute
of technology erschaffen nach dem
vorbild des europäischen polytechnikums
begegnen sich hier studierende und
professoren aus aller welt dass mati
genießt einen exzellenten ruf im bereich
technologischer forschung und lehre auf
dem campus steht sogar ein nuklearer
versuchsreaktor seit 1961 verfügt das
mrt über ein institut für linguistik und
philosophie mit seinem prominentesten
vertreter sind wir zum interview
verabredet
nur am dzemski die haben bestimmt mehr
als ein dutzend us amerikanische
wahlkämpfe erlebt wahlen 2012 wie
erleben sie diese wahlen die wahl
verlieren jedes jahr an bedeutung
aus guten gründen vielleicht erinnern
sie sich daran dass 2008 kurz nach den
letzten präsidentschaftswahl nach obamas
sieg die werbeindustrie ihre
jahresversammlung hatte an diesem anlass
prämiert sie jeweils die beste
marketingkampagne des jahres in jenem
jahr fiel ihre wahl auf präsident obama
er schlug apple computer es ist wichtig
sich etwas vor augen die werbeindustrie
die zur gewaltigen pr industrie gehört
hat viele verschiedene funktionen und
eines ihrer wichtigsten ziele ist es
märkte zu untergraben
[Musik]
in wirtschafts vorlesungen lernt man
merkte würden darauf gründen das
rationale käufer rationale
entscheidungen treffen
darauf basieren viele
wirtschaftstheorien schaltet man aber
den fernseher ein sieht man das ist das
ziel der werbung ist informierte
konsument
schaffen die irrationale entscheidet so
wird das funktionieren der märkte
untergraben würde die geschäftswelt den
märkten vertrauen würden firmen wie
general motors oder colgate zahnpasta
mit ihrer werbung informieren
das ist unser produkt das sind seine
eigenschaften und sie würden ein paar
kritische urteile von konsumenten
anfügen und das sind 5 sekunden
aber so funktioniert werbung nicht sie
verleitet konsumenten durch täuschung
zum kauf von produkten also dieselbe
industrie vorwahlen für kandidaten wird
tut sie fest sie versucht die demokratie
zu untergraben indem sie uninformierte
wählerschaft die irrational wählen
man spricht also nicht über inhalte mit
gutem grund die öffentliche meinung
orientiert sich nicht daran wie die
politik wichtige themen anpackt deshalb
liegt die werbung den fokus auf die
person des kandidaten und seine nette
familie
auch die kandidaten sprechen lieber
nicht über inhalte
mitt romney verzichtet praktisch
vollständig darauf beschäftigt sie haben
in einem buch media control auch diese
theorie dargelegt dass eigentlich die
medien unsere welt sehr stark
kontrollieren
jetzt habe ich ja eigentlich gefragt was
eigentlich jetzt in diesen wochen los
ist wie tief sie waren ja leben wenn ich
ihnen zuhöre dann würden sie also sagen
es geht gar nicht um themen sondern
letztendlich nur darum wer die bessere
kampagne hat zunächst einmal glaube ich
nicht dass die medien die welt
kontrollieren
sie versuchen vielleicht die ansicht nun
das verhalten der bevölkerung zu
kontrollieren aber das heißt noch lange
nicht dass es ihnen gelingt doch das ist
eine frage für sich
das buch das sie angesprochen haben
die art und weise wie ereignisse geformt
präsentiert und ausgewählt werden
abhängig vom druck dem die medien
ausgesetzt sind
das tun sie ganz unterschiedlich aber
man kann auch ein paar generelle dinge
dazu sagen eine ganz andere frage ist
wie wirksam die methoden der medien sind
offensichtlich haben sie wenig erfolg
deshalb ist der graben zwischen der
politik und der öffentlichen meinung so
tief denn die öffentliche meinung wird
nicht durch die elitäre vermittlung der
politik kontrolliert sie wird davon
beeinflusst aber nicht kontrollieren was
die wahlen betrifft gebe es gute gründe
über kritische themen zu reden
ich kann ihnen beispiele zum beispiel
die us wirtschaft das zentrale anliegen
der amerikaner wie umfragen zeigen ist
das hauptproblem für die bevölkerung und
das zu recht dass es nicht genug
arbeitsstellen gibt gegen 23 millionen
menschen sind entweder arbeitslos oder
unterbeschäftigt oder haben komplett
aufgegeben
das ist ein gigantisches problem eine
menschliche katastrophe und auch eine
katastrophe für die wirtschaft gesagt
dass obama daran gemessen werden wie
robert die arbeitslosigkeit in den griff
kriegt und die magische grenze von acht
prozent unterschreiten richtig aber wie
sehr wahrscheinlich bemerkt haben weder
die medien noch die wahlkampagne
fokussieren darauf was sind denn die
themen hat die fokussiert wird
sie fokussieren auf das große thema in
den medien und in öffentlichen
diskussionen ist die frage was tun wir
mit dem das defizit ist jedoch für die
bevölkerung zweitrangig zurecht finde
ich ich kann ihnen auch sagen warum
tatsächlich ist das defizit für die
banken die finanzinstitute usw
wichtig und darauf konzentrieren sich
die medien und die wahlkampagne auch die
öffentlichkeit hat eine meinung darüber
wie man das defizit verringern sollte
das weiß man von umfrage zum beispiel
indem militärausgaben beschränkt und die
steuern für die reichen erhöht würden
aber nicht indem man leistungen für die
soziale sicherheit und die
gesundheitsvorsorge in der politik wird
das gegenteil angestellt
beide kandidaten wollen die
militärausgaben erhöhen die republikaner
mehr als die demokraten
was die steuern anbelangt reden sie zwar
davon die reichen höher zu besteuern
aber es ist klar dass das nicht
geschehen wird und die reichen sind in
den usa eindeutig zu tief versteuert
zudem wollen die kandidaten die
sozialleistungen kürzen gegen den willen
der bevölkerung die medien wieder
spiegeln also die meinung der elite die
öffentlichkeit hat andere prioritäten
was im wahlkampf zur sprache kommt und
dem was wirklich wichtig ist für die
leute eine spannung tut sich auf es gibt
auch die spannung innerhalb der
bevölkerung
paul auster der us-amerikanische
schriftsteller hat in einem interview
mit der deutschen wochenzeitung die zeit
gesagt usa das ist ein geteiltes land
wie zu zeiten des bürgerkrieges erfahren
sie zu einer solchen these die
bevölkerung ist bei vielen themen
geteilter meinung
aber bei vielen auch nicht in die
öffentliche meinung in den usa wird
genau erforscht das ist eines der
hauptanliegen der politikwissenschaft es
gibt viele umfragen die sehr gründlich
und zuverlässig sind
man weiß also recht genau wie die
bevölkerung denkt nehmen wir die meinung
der tea-party-bewegung das sind leute
die keine einmischung der regierung
durch schaut man ihre haltung an ist
diese mehr oder weniger
sozialdemokratisch
sie wollen mehr ausgaben für bildung und
gesundheit und mehr unterstützung für
frauen mit abhängigen aber sie wollen
keine wulff die wurde von der regierung
dämonisiert vor allem von ronald reagan
und von den medien
wohlfahrt bedeutet für die leute eine
schwarze frau die im cardillac ins
sozialamt fährt um ihr geld
entgegenzunehmen
die leute wollen keine wohltaten er
ausgaben für bedürftige was natürlich
wohlfahrt ist was die außenpolitik
betrifft zum beispiel die ausland hilfe
finden die meisten es werde zu viel
dafür ausgegeben fragt man die leute
doch wie hoch ihrer meinung nach die
ausland hilfe sei sind ihre schätzungen
viel höher als die tatsächlichen
ausgaben
die leute wollen ausland hilfe finden
aber sie sei zu hoch
es zeigt wie erfolgreich die bevölkerung
falsch informiert wird manchmal ist
dieser erfolg erstaunlich dass 40 uhr
hob eine republikanische geprägte reise
institution im süden der usa
eine umfrage über die haltung der leute
zum steuersystem
die meisten befragten fanden die steuern
für reiche sollten beträchtlich erhöht
werden
doch sie favorisierten romneys
steuerprogramm dass
steuererleichterungen für die reichen
vorsieht
denn die bevölkerung genug irre geführt
wird bekommt man solche resultate aber
die bevölkerung ist verwirrt weil die
fakten so sehr verschleiert werden dass
die leute sie nicht sehen können
sie haben jetzt sozusagen auch betont
wie die beiden parteien also die
demokraten und die republikaner in
vielen dingen sich einig sind sie haben
herausgestrichen dass sie denken beide
würden zum beispiel die militärausgaben
schlussendlich erhöhen
beide würden nicht wirklich die
reicheren leute stärker besteuern
sie haben ja auch immer wieder
eigentlich ist die usa 1 1 parteien land
kürzlich hatten dir die zürcher
filmfestspiele in zürich da hat die
oscar-preisträgerin susan sarandon
gesagt was die usa wirklich brauchen ist
eine dritte starke partei wenn sie den
zum stimmen braucht es eine dritte
parteien und warum haben wir nicht
einmal haben die usa kein proporzsystem
daher ist es für eine kleine partei
praktisch unmöglich in der regierung
vertreten zu sein
ein anderer wichtiger fakt ist die rolle
des geldes in den wahlen heute
verschlingt der wahlkampf so viel dass
dies zum hauptthema geworden das geht
weit zurück mehr als 100 jahre bereits
der große kampagnen manager marc hanna
ein republikanischer geschäftsmann der
in den 1800 80er jahren mehrere
wahlkampagnen organisierte wies darauf
hin als er gefragt wurde was bei einer
kampagne wichtig sei sagte er
drei dinge geld geld und das dritte weiß
ich nicht mehr
das war vor mehr als 100 jahren
heute sind die summen radikal gestiegen
vor allem in den letzten jahren gab es
eine verlagerung von der qualität zur
quandt auch das wurde genau erforscht
der politikwissenschaftler thomas
vergessen hat gute arbeit in dem bereich
geleistet und gezeigt
man kann anhand der konzentration der
kampagnen geldern recht gut
prognostizieren welche politik eine
zukünftige administration verfolgen wird
schaut man genauer hin sind die gründe
nicht verwunderlich
ein buch von martin gehlen zeigt
detailliert eine der haupt erkenntnisse
der zeitgenössischen politikwissenschaft
rund 70 prozent der bevölkerung haben
keinen einfluss auf die politik
das sind die wenig bemittelte je höher
das einkommen desto stärker ist der
einfluss zuoberst auf der einkommens-
rangliste ist die einflussnahme enorm
mit anderen worten die reichen bekommen
was sie wollen und der großteil der
bevölkerung ist irrelevant nur von einer
partei regiert und sie nennen diese
partei die business party ich möchte sie
noch einmal fragen würden sie diese
these wirklich so vertreten eigentlich
gibt es nur eine partei es gibt nicht
wirklich unterschiede zwischen den
demokraten und den republikanern
ich denke es gibt unterschiede
und es macht manchmal sinn für die eine
oder die andere partei zu stimmen
aber der satz den sie zitiert haben ist
nicht von mir sondern von charles reid
mills einem der führenden amerikanischen
soziologen seiner zeit
er schrieb vor etwa 50 jahren dass die
usa eine business partei hat mit zwei
fraktionen den demokraten und den
republikanern
sie sind verschieden oft sogar sehr
verschieden ich bin eigentlich
überrascht wie groß der unterschied in
den letzten 20 jahren geworden ist im
amerikanischen wahlsystem sind ein paar
interessante dinge geschehen welche die
veränderungen in der wirtschaft
widerspiegeln die republikaner sehen
sich nicht mehr als normale
regierungspartei sie sind sehr uniform
geworden und verlangen die strikte
befolgung ihres katechismus verglichen
damit geht die kommunistische partei
sanft mit ihren mitgliedern um der
katechismus verlangt dient den reichen
und mächtigen sozusagen mit haut und
haar
das macht keine
regierungspartei so holt man keine
stimmt die republikaner mussten also
etwas tun was sie taten sieht man in den
vormachen
sie mussten teile der bevölkerung
mobilisieren die bisher nie politisch
mobilisiert wurden
wie sie wissen ist die us bevölkerung
sehr religiös viel religiöser als die
anderer länder
das geht zurück auf die kolonialisierung
als die hälfte der bevölkerung glaubte
die welt sei vor 10.000 jahren
erschaffen wird diese leute konnten
bisher politisch nicht mobilisiert
werden und das ist den republikanern
gelungen
sie sahen sich gezwungen sie zu ihrer
basis zu machen
es gibt in den usa auch viele sogenannte
native und wir sagen wir müssten uns
gegen fremde eindringlinge verteidigen
fällt auch diese bevölkerungsgruppe
wurde mobilisiert
das resultat zeigt sich bei
republikanischen debatten die sind
irgendwie surreal und haben praktisch
nichts mit der realität zu tun
doch so reden die kandidaten zur basis
die sie mobilisiert haben
interessanterweise sind die vertreter
des republikanischen establishments aus
der geschäftswelt nicht sehr erfreut
darüber
sie müssen diese leute mobilisieren doch
deren haltung missfällt ihm
und jedes mal wenn ein kandidat der
basis den aufstieg schaffte wie michael
beckmann herman cain newt gingrich rick
santorum wurde sofort geharnischte
negativ werbung betrieben um ihn zu
zerstören
bis das establishment endlich seine
wunschkandidaten hatte einen reichen
geschäftsmann mitt romney und dieser
musste der politischen basis schmackhaft
gemacht werden
das ist keine politische lage sie
versucht einzig die regierung zu nehmen
und zu blockieren zum beispiel durch
verschleppungstaktik ehrlich gesagt
bräuchte es erstmal eine 2
die republikaner sind in den letzten 30
jahren sehr stark nach rechts gerutscht
das ist eine lange geschichte gehört
aber zum neoliberalen angriff auf die
bevölkerung der viel verändert hat
auch die demokraten sind nach rechts
gerutscht es wird allgemein moniert es
gebe keine moderaten republikaner mehr
das stimmt nicht ganz
es gibt sie sie heißen einfach mitte
demokraten
beide parteien sind also nach rechts
gerutscht die republikaner stecken so
tief in den taschen der profitgierigen
wirtschaft dass man ein teleskop braucht
und sie zu finden und die demokraten
liegen nicht weit hinter ihm aber der
großteil der bevölkerung ist anders im
us wahlsystem braucht es also weniger
eine andere partei nötig sind vielmehr
veränderungen in der politischen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen kultur
damit andere meinungen ins blickfeld
rücken
nehmen wir die new york times von heute
morgen
darin ist ein ausführlicher
interessanter artikel über psychologen
die kinder behandeln und ihnen
medikamente gehen
es sind vor allem kinder aus ärmlichen
gegenden die schlechte schulleistungen
erbringen diesen kindern geben sie
medikamente damit ihre leistungen besser
werden im interview sagen diese
psychologen mit diesen kindern ist
nichts falsch es liegt an der
gesellschaft diese unterstützt die
schule und nicht und unternimmt nichts
gegen die hohe armut inder die unter
diesen bedingungen aufwachsen sind nicht
gut in der schule also geben wir ihnen
medikamente
interessant ist ihre argumentation
sie sagen die gesellschaft hat
beschlossen nicht die gesellschaft
sondern die kinder zu verändern
das hat aber nicht die gesellschaft
entschieden nicht die 70 prozent die
keinen einfluss auf die politik
hinter dieser entscheidung stehen jene
die adams miss masters of the universe
nannte das ist ein kleiner prozent
als der bevölkerung bevor das nicht
grundlegend geändert wird werden wir
keine funktionierende demokratie haben
etwas muss klargestellt werden
die usa gehören zu den freiesten ländern
der welt in vieler hinsicht ist die
gesellschaft sehr bewundert wird
es ist das einzige land der welt das ich
kenne in dem die meinungsfreiheit ernst
genommen werde
das ist ein sehr wichtiger wert ich
liebe keine ich finde man sollte
menschen lieben nicht länder
und wenn wir unsere gesellschaft
bewerten können wir viel gutes und viel
schlechtes finden und die schlechten
dinge müssen geändert werden was aber in
einem nicht funktionierenden politischen
system unmöglich auch gerne sprechen
sich eine person die die
meinungsfreiheit so sehr hoch hält dass
sie sogar immer mal wieder auch personen
verteidigt haben die in verruf geraten
sind extrem in verruf geraten sind sie
haben beispielsweise 2010 in einem
communiqué die freilassung von barcelona
verlangt einen franzosen der aus
holocaust lüge eine strafe verbüßen
musste
gibt es nicht grenzen der
meinungsfreiheit oder warum verteidigen
sie holocaust leugner
diesbezüglich kann man zwei positionen
einnehmen einerseits die position von
stalin und hitler das bedeutet man ist
für freie meinungsäusserung zu fernwald
ii geäußerte meinung gutheißt
andererseits die position der aufklärung
das bedeutet die freie meinungsäußerung
gilt gerade für meinungen die man
ablehnt und es gibt nichts dazwischen
jeder ist für freie meinungsäusserung
sofern er gleicher meinung ist ob ich
wirklich für freie meinungsäusserung bin
zeigt sich erst wenn ich sie auch hoch
halte bei ansichten die ich ablehne
es geht also darum ob wir grundsätzlich
an die ideale von jefferson glauben
das heißt jeder kann seine meinung frei
äußern und in der interaktion zeigt sich
die wahrheit
diese kann sich nur zeigen wenn man
seine ansichten frei äußern kann
nehmen wir die leugnung des holocaust
es gibt in den usa bekannte
holocaust-leugnern einige sind
professoren an großen universitäten und
haben bücher darüber geschrieben
da aber niemand mit dem finger auf sie
zeigt beachtet man sie nicht
gesetzt den fall die new york times
verurteilt sie auf der frontseite worauf
das gericht entscheidet dass sie ins
gefängnis müssen
dadurch werden sie bekannt und die leute
wollen ihre bücher lesen
so funktioniert es in frankreich aber
ich finde die usa handeln richtig ein
pragmatisches argument besser man macht
kein verbot weil sonst gibt es ein
riesen geschrei um solche meinungen und
dann werden die leute erst recht auf
eine plattform gehoben wo sie ihre ideen
verbreiten können
die andere idee dich jetzt vorgestellt
haben war wir sollten lernen auch leute
zu akzeptieren die meinung vertreten die
wir nicht mögen aber da würde ich sie
gerne fragen sie hat mich am anfang
jetzt über die medien gesprochen über
die schwierigkeit dass die medien uns
auch in die irre führen können dass das
volk für dumm verkauft werden kann wo
ist denn da der ausgleich ich meine
zuweilen möchte man vielleicht nicht
dass leute ihre falschen meinungen
verbreiten angst davor hat dass eine
hetze entstehen könnte das schlichtweg
ihre meinungen vertreten werden die
wirklich gefährlich sind sie berichte
es besteht tatsächlich ein unterschied
ist das wissen der prinzipiellen
befürwortung der freien meinungsäußerung
und der pragmatischen haltung dass es
das beste ist was man tun kann damit die
wahrheit ans tageslicht kommt das sind
unterschiedliche positionen
ich dachte sie decken sich aber sie sind
verschieden und wichtiger ist die
prinzipielle befürwortung nehmen
zuerst möchte ich sagen ich lese die
ich lese internationale zeitung und
lerne viel daraus darin werden aber auch
dinge verdreht nehmen wir den artikel
den ich heute morgen gelesen und erwähnt
habe
daraus lernt man etwas das gar nicht
dargelegt wurde nämlich das tiefe
missverständnis der elite sie meint die
gesellschaft wolle die kinder und nicht
die gesellschaft verändert es ist aber
nicht die gesellschaft die das will das
ist nur die sicht der elite und zeigt
die indoktrinierung der elite aber wir
können es lesen und sagen so
funktioniert das nicht
wir kennen andere fakten nicht die
bevölkerung sondern die manager wollen
okay das ist wichtig wenn die medien
dinge verdrehen können wir das
kritisieren und nach möglichkeiten
suchen es zu ändern und die leute
richtig zu informieren
darum geht es aktivisten vor 50 jahren
wollten die bürgerrechtler ansichten und
verhaltensweisen verändern die damals
weit verbreitet waren und von den medien
und der öffentlichen meinung unterstützt
wurden
lincoln er war ein großartiger mann aber
er dachte es sei ein fehler den
schwarzen nach ihrer befreiung zu
erlauben in den usa zu bleiben
er sagte man müsse sei nach liberia oder
haiti zurückschicken das war die
position von abraham lincoln und deshalb
brauchte es die aufklärung
darum braucht dass bildung aktivismus
und organisationen nehmen wir etwas aus
der jüngeren vergangenheit die stellung
der frauen in der us-verfassung galt
früher das was im englischen grundrecht
verankert
basierend auf dem kompendium des
englischen juristen william blackstone
wurde die frau als eigentum betrachtet
als eigentum ihres vaters und dann ihres
ehemannes
sie hatte deshalb kein wahlrecht unter
anderem weil es unfair gewesen wäre ihr
das wahlrecht zuzugestehen
denn ihr ehemann hätte dann zwei stimmen
bekommen da sie natürlich hätte wählen
müssen wie ihr besitzer das galt noch
vor wenigen jahren
bis 1975 das ist noch nicht so lange her
hatten frauen auch nicht das recht
geschworene an bundesgerichten zu sein
denn sie waren keine bürger sondern
besitzt das wurde geändert
wenn es auch lange gedauert hat und es
gehört zu den wichtigsten
errungenschaften der aktivisten der 60er
jahre
dass sich die haltung praxis und die
gesetze bezüglich der rechte der frau
und grundlegend geändert haben genauso
werden fortschritte erzielt sprechen sie
sind seit 55 jahren hier am 1
sie sind ein berühmter linguist ein
sprachwissenschaftler
sie haben damals vor ungefähr 50 jahren
für furore gesorgt mit der sogenannten
generativen grammatik der idee dass
unsere sprechen uns irgendwie angeboren
ist dass die sprachlichen strukturen
dass wir die im kopf tragen dass wir die
von kindsbeinen an haben und leben nicht
allein durch nachahmung unter sprechen
erst entsteht das nannte man damals die
kognitive wende
wir lernen sprechen auch weil die eben
diese sprach strukturen bereits in uns
tragen bei der geburt was ist von dieser
großen these die damals so sehr für
furore gesorgt hat heute noch geblieben
wo stehen sie mit ihrer forschung heute
ist dieses konzert mehr oder weniger
anerkannt zumindest wenn man seriöse
forschung staaten konsultiert
man hat aber auch viel dazugelernt
in der 1950 er jahren meinte man noch
dieses sprachsystem sei sehr komplex
geschehen der mensch müsse zur
bewältigung der vielfalt und komplexität
von sprachen über extrem ausgeklügelte
innere strukturen verfügt
wir merkten dass dies nicht der fall
sein konnte sonst hätte sich die
sprachfähigkeit gar nicht entwickeln
können wir wissen nicht viel über die
evolution der sprache aber bekannt ist
dass dieser entwicklungsschritt in der
evolutionsgeschichte erst vor kurzem
erfolgte er muss daher sehr einfach
gewesen sei doch was die menschen
produzieren ist sehr komplex
das ist also ein großes problem das in
den letzten jahren zwar nicht gelöst
aber zumindest stark vereinfacht werden
konnte wir entdeckten tiefer liegende
prinzipien in vorgängen von denen man
früher dachte sie würden komplexen
regeln folgen
[Musik]
aus den forschungsergebnissen wurden
hypothesen abgeleitet die zwar noch
nicht erhärtet aber doch sehr plausibel
sind nämlich dass alle sprachen den
exakt gleichen regeln voll dass also
englisch und suaheli aus der sicht des
mars bewohner dasselbe sind
es gibt zwar unterschiede aber die sind
nur oberflächlich grundsätzlich folgen
die sprachen den immer gleichen regeln
und die sind relativ einfach
das ist zwar immer noch eine
idealtypische vorstellung aber etwas das
die wissenschaft mit der zeit wohl
erhalten können wenn sie das erreicht
kann sie die diversität und komplexität
der sprachen erklären und zugleich die
tatsache dass dieser evolutionsschritt
erst vor kurzem und so rasch erfolgt es
lohnt sich in erinnerung zu rufen dass
man zwar viel über die entwicklung der
sprachen geschrieben hat
aber eigentlich wenig darüber bekannt
ist man weiß mit ziemlicher sicherheit
dass sich die sprachfähigkeit seit etwa
50.000 jahren nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt hat wir wissen dass aus
folgendem grund er fehlt nimmt man ein
kleinkind aus dem urwald von amazonien
von einem stamm der seit 10.000 jahren
keinen kontakt mit anderen menschen
hatte und bringt es nach boston wird es
perfektes boston englisch lernen und
sprechen und umgekehrt
ein kind von boston und ein kind von
amazonien haben also dieselben fehler
es gibt individuelle unterschiede aber
keine standesunterschiede seit 50.000
jahren ist also nichts entscheidendes
passiert
über weitere 50.000 oder 100.000 jahre
zurück findet man nichts voraus man auf
das vorhandensein einer sprache
schließen könnte
es gibt aber anthropologische und
archäologische hinweise dass in diesem
kleinen zeitfenster das
evolutionsgeschichtlich gesehen nicht
mehr als ein augenzwinkern ist etwas
dramatisches passiert es muss eine art
explosion kreativer aktivität gegeben
haben
symbolische repräsentationen komplexe
wort familien soziale strukturen und so
weiter das wird von paläontologen
allgemein als entwicklung der sprache
beschrieben
aber diese entwicklung passierte wie
gesagt in einem sehr kleinen zeitfenster
das heißt was immer auch passiert ist
muss sehr einfach gewesen sein
eine kleine veränderung des gehirns aus
der sich dann diese fundamentalen
kreativen fähigkeiten entwickelt haben
vorher waren unsere vorfahren
nicht mehr als ein oder vielen hominiden
arten in afrika anatomisch gibt es die
modernen menschen seit hunderttausenden
von jahren aber ihre kognitive
entwicklung ist anscheinend erst vor
kurzem erfolgt und bald darauf haben sie
afrika verlassen und die ganze welt
geholt
das ging sehr schnell sie gingen nach
papua neuguinea australien überall hin
alle anderen hominiden arten wurden
eliminiert
es gibt seit 30.000 jahren keine
hominiden wäre wenn ich ihnen zuhöre
dann merke ich sie sind ein universum
wenn es um die ganze sprachwissenschaft
geht man merkte ihnen an wie sehr sie
dieses thema liebe und ich kann ihnen
nur sagen alle meine freunde die
sprachwissenschaften studiert haben die
alle haben ihr schema gelernt wir haben
gelernt wie man wir haben das schon ski
bäumchen genannt wie wir diese
generative grammatik auf die sprache
anwenden mussten haben das in prüfungen
niedergeschrieben
allerdings kennt man sie auch oder
eigentlich auch fast vor allem als
politischer aktivist
es gibt die geschichte von ihnen oder
von von dem was sie produzieren und
politischen büchern doch während des
irak krieges an vielen universitäten auf
der ganzen welt graffiti erschienen sind
mit den worten ried dzemski lest chomsky
wie bringen sie diese beiden existenzen
zusammen ein so berühmter
sprachwissenschaftler zu sein und ein so
berühmter politischer aktivist fast
schon ein politisches idol zu sein und
keine möglichkeit die beiden dinge
zusammenzubringen
und es ist doch unglaublich ich kann
politischer aktivist und gleichzeitig
sagen wir algebraische topologie oder
botaniker sein
es gibt keinen zusammenhang eigentlich
gibt es sogar eine art verbindung aber
sie ist ziemlich abstrakt darüber wurde
im siebzehnten und dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert spekuliert
diese idee geht auf schriften von
gelehrten wie wilhelm von humboldt
zurück der zu den begründern des
klassischen liberalismus zählt und ein
großer lingo ist lang auch einem suisse
hat darüber geschrieben ihre libertären
politischen ansichten gründeten auf
ihrer sicht der menschlichen natur
sie sahen das wesen des menschen vor
allem in seiner freiheit unabhängig zu
forschen und kreativ zu sein
humboldt drückte das mit einem schönen
bild aus er sagte wenn ein handwerker
einen schönen gegenstand im auftrag
schafft bewundern wer was er machte aber
verachten wer er ist nämlich ein
werkzeug in den händen anderer ex miss
sagte etwas sehr ähnliches
viele meinen er habe die arbeitsteilung
idealisiert und zwar aufgrund des ersten
paragraphen seines werkes wohlstand der
nationen wenige dieser gehen über die
ersten 100 seiten hinaus und lesen seine
scharfe kritik der arbeitsteilung in
einem zivilisierten land muss die
regierung einschreiten und die
arbeitsteilung verhindern
sie macht aus den menschen dumme und
unwissende kreaturen denn sie agieren
auf kommando und verrichten
routinearbeiten doch der mensch schuld
frei und kreativ sein und wählen dürfen
was er tun will
das ist der kern der libertären ideen
aber auch der kern linguistisch
das geht auf der karte die karts sprach
zwar nicht über politische aspekte aber
gelehrte wie humboldt und smith
schöpften aus dem katalanischen
gedankengut ob bewusst oder unbewusst
war es teil des intellektuellen
hintergrund von kt sie ahnen und
antipathie sie ahnen
wir nennen
descartes einem philosophen aber
eigentlich war er wissenschaftlicher was
wir heute philosophie nennen war damals
wissenschaft sein grundprinzip war das
fundament der modernen wissenschaft von
galileo bisher sah die welt als komplexe
maschine eine maschine die von einem
begabten handwerker hätte konstruiert
werden können
mit betriebe hebeln und reden die sich
gegenseitig antreiben und galileo ging
die moderne wissenschaft von der
grundannahme aus wenn man etwas nicht
mechanisch erklären kann ist es nicht
einsehbar und somit auch nicht erklärbar
die kag dachte er könne die welt
mechanische klären aber darüber hinaus
verstand etwas wesentliches was wir
nicht erklären können ist die tatsache
dass jeder mensch die fähigkeit hat
endlos neue ausdrücke zu kreieren
er kann seine gedanken auf eine komplett
neue und verständliche art ausdrücken
ohne dass er durch externe impulse oder
innere befindlichkeiten gesteuert wird
den situationen angemessen aber nicht
durch sie verursachten diese erkenntnis
ist korrekt so viel wir wissen und sie
ist die basis für die karts theorie des
geistes er kam zum schluss da dies
mechanisch nicht möglich sei brauche es
eine zweite substanz die regie tanzen
die denkende substanz und dann folgt die
frage wie hängen die beiden zusammen nun
dieses bild hielt sich nicht lange
newton glaubte daran aber er widerlegte
es später zu seiner eigenen großen
enttäuschung
er zeigte auf dass dieses bild der
maschine
auf die welt zur schrift denn phänomene
wie die bewegung der planeten oder die
gezeiten seitdem unterworfen was man
damals mystischer eigenschaften nannte
nämlich an ist jung und abschluss die
großen wissenschaftler jener zeit wie
leibniz und eigens verdammte newton
dafür dass er auf plastische mystizismus
zurückgriff und newton gab ihnen recht
er sagte das ist eine absurdität die
kein wissenschaftler akzeptieren
aber sobald sich die erkenntnis einmal
durchgesetzt hatte dass es keine
maschinen im sinn der frühen modernen
wissenschaft gab musste man auch nicht
länger annehmen dass die mentalen
eigenschaften vom rest der welt getrennt
sein ulmer kann bis zu john lobb
zurückgehen der teilweise unter dem
einfluss von juden sagte wenn normale
materie so mysteriöse eigenschaften hat
die anziehung und abstoßung dann gibt es
keinen grund nicht anzunehmen dass
materie auch denken kann
er setzte das in einen theologischen
zusammenhang mit der schöpfung einen
ganzen bogen haben sie geschlagen haben
sich von der frage wie sie ihr
wissenschaftler leben zusammen bringen
mit ihrem leben als politische stimme
als politischer kritiker auch und sie
haben nichts quasi die antwort gegeben
dass sie gegen die arbeitsteilung sind
oder zumindest die arbeitsteilung auch
für gefährlich halten könnten
jetzt wenn ihr bei diesen politischen
aktivismus noch einmal ansetzen
sie haben ja eigentlich ihre stimme erst
mal so richtig erhoben als es um den
vietnam krieg ging sie waren einer der
intellektuellen die sich ganz stark
gegen den vietnamkrieg ausgesprochen
haben und seither mischen sie sich immer
wieder ein
und ich würde sie gerne fragen einer der
konflikte für den sie sich immer wieder
versuchen eine lösung zu präsentieren
oder sich einsetzen für die für die
schwierigkeiten in diesem kontext ist
der israel palästina konflikt 2010
wollten sie nach gaza reisen sie wurden
nicht hineingelassen sie nun zurück
gehalten an der jordanisch israelischen
grenze jetzt habe ich gehört wollen sie
wieder nach gaza warum wollen sie nach
gaza meinen ersten politischen artikel
habe ich 1939 für eine schülerzeitung
geschrieben
darin warnte ich vor dem wachsenden
faschismus in europa das war nachdem
francos truppen barcelona eingenommen
haben
die schrieb wie österreich die
tschechoslowakei und nun auch spanien
gefallen sein
die verbreitung des faschismus war sehr
beängstigend
ich war damals zehn jahre alt und
seither habe ich nicht mehr aufgehört
politisch aktiv zu sein
im nahen osten war ich in den 1940 er
jahren als teenager und zionistische
aktivist heute nennt man das
antizionismus damals bezeichnete man uns
als zionisten aber wir hatten die
gleiche haltung wir waren gegen den
jüdischen staat und unterstützten eine
zwei staaten lösung basierend auf
arabisch jüdische zusammenarbeit
das wurde damals von der zionistischen
bewegung unterstützt
ich erzähle jetzt nicht alles aber ich
bin diesbezüglich immer sehr aktiv
gewesen und auch bei anderen ereignissen
wie der britischen intervention in
griechenland 1944 auch darüber habe ich
geschrieben
damals war ich 15 jahre alt es war
nichts nennenswertes aber meine haltung
habe ich nie geändert
man kann verschiedene dinge tun als der
vietnamkrieg begann habe ich mich
stärker eingemischt
nicht nur mit artikeln und reden sondern
durch aktiven widerstand ich
organisierte steuer verweigerungen und
half mit bei der unterstützung der
wehrpflicht verweigerung ich wäre
deswegen beinahe im gefängnis gelandet
eine aktivistische haltung hat sich
nicht grundlegend geändert
außenpolitik auf die feinde von dem
damaligen us präsidenten nixon geschafft
haben
was kritisieren sie denn an der us
amerikanischen außenpolitik
hauptsächlich kann man das so quasi auf
einen punkt reduzieren oder
zusammenfassen was sie am meisten sterne
grund kritik ist dass die usa handeln
als gehöre ihnen die welt
und wenn sich jemand diesem
besitzanspruch widersetzt müsse man ihn
stoppen
nehmen wir die schlagzeilen über den
iran und stellen eine einfache frage
waren sollte der iran eine bedrohung
sein
das land hat eine marode regierung aber
viele länder haben der regierung saudi
arabien der wichtigste verbündete der
usa in der region hat wohl eine
schlimmere regierung was macht also aus
dem iran eine bedrohung
gemäss der vorherrschenden öffentlichen
meinung in europa ist israel die größte
bedrohung der öffentlichen meinung in
den arabischen nationen ist israel die
hauptbedrohung und die usa sind die
zweitgrößte bedrohung die arabische welt
mag den iran nicht aber er ist für sie
keine bedrohung
warum sind also die usa und ihre
verbündeten so besessen von dieser idee
der iranischen bedrohung
wir haben antworten auf diese fragen und
zwar vom pentagon und vom us
geheimdienst
man kann sie nachlesen in ihren
berichten über die globale
sicherheitssituation ich habe schon
daraus zitiert die presse schreibt nicht
darüber aber sie sind öffentlich
zugänglich und dort wird der iran als
ernstzunehmende bedrohung dargestellt
vor allem weil das land ein
abschreckungsmittel gegen die usa
entwickeln könnte sie sagen sollte der
iran atomwaffen herstellen können wäre
das teil seiner abschreckungs artikeln
sie betonen die iran habe begrenzte
macht raus übungsmöglichkeiten das land
verfüge über eine verteidigungsstrategie
es könne zwar nicht macht ausüben aber
womöglich ein abschreckungs waffe
herstellen was verrät das über uns
das wäre keine abschreckung tolerieren
wir müssen frei agieren und macht und
gewalt anwenden können und zwar überall
und uneingeschränkt anders gesagt wir
uns gehört die welt
dasselbe gilt für den konflikt zwischen
den usa und china in china kann man
vieles beanstanden seine nachbarn sind
unglücklich über sein
wirtschaftswachstum und seine kriegslust
wir haben ein problem das man
klassisches sicherheitsziele maria das
heißt china und die usa haben beide ein
existenzielles bedürfnis das miteinander
kollidiert und zu den dingen gehört die
schon oft zu krieg geführt haben was ist
dieses existenzielle bedrohung für die
chinesin ist es die kontrolle ihrer
gewässer vor ihren küsten denn das sind
ihre haupt handelswege wenn sie öl aus
dem nahen osten brauchen wird es auf
diesem weg transportiert auch die usa
wollen diese gewässer kontrollieren der
konflikt betrifft weder die karibik noch
den ostatlantik es geht um die gewässer
vor china eine bedrohung unserer
kontrolle über diese gewässer ist für
die usa nicht tolerierbar nehmen wir die
kubakrise im kalten krieg vor bald 50
jahre ein bedeutendes ereignis
es brachte die welt an den rand eines
atomkriegs der die nazis fähre hätte
zerstören können auf dem höhepunkt der
krise am 26 27
oktober 1962 nach die premierminister
kozlov dem us präsidenten kennedy ein
angebot zur beendigung der krise
er bot an die russischen raketen von
kuba abzuziehen wenn die usa ihre
raketen die sie schon lange
in der türkei stationiert hatten
abziehen würden kennedy lehnte ab er war
einzig mit einem geheimabkommen
einverstanden denn die raketen waren
veraltet und er hatte deren abzug
bereits angeordnet sie sollten durch
polaris u boote im mittelmeer ersetzt
werden die praktisch unzerstörbar und
viel tödlicher waren aber er musste das
prinzip erhärten dass wir das recht
haben privaten einzukesseln mit
massivsten mitteln und tausenden von
soldaten während andere nicht das recht
haben raketen außerhalb ihrer
hoheitsgebiete zu stationieren
das macht sinn wenn uns die welt gehört
und das ist nicht ungewöhnlich so
funktionieren großmächte die usa sind
ungewöhnlich aber nur weil sie so
mächtig sind die verträge von 19.45
gaben den usa eine machtposition die in
der weltgeschichte einmalig war so gross
ist ihre macht nicht mehr aber immer
noch beträchtlich zurückgehen
sie selber sind ja ursprünglich jude und
ein verbreitetes vorurteilen was
kursiert ist das im grunde genommen die
juden in amerika die außenpolitik
bestimmen
stimmen sie dieser position zu so viel
kann ich dazu sagen wenn die interessen
der jüdischen lobby mehr oder weniger
mit den zielen des us machtzentrums
übereinstimmen ist sie ziemlich
einflussreich aber wenn sie gegen diese
ziele ist schwindet diese einfluss davon
zeugen viele fälle
gerade hat sich ein solcher fall zum
dreißigsten mal gejährt
die israelische invasion in den libanon
20.000 menschen wurden getötet der
südlibanon praktisch zerstört
die version war von regen unterstützt
wurde
aber mitte august sah die us regierung
dass der krieg ihren interessen schadet
deshalb befahl regen premierminister
berlin die operation zu beenden
beginn war sehr verärgert denn er meinte
er habe arafat eingebunkert und sei
daran ihn zu erledigen
doch regen befahl ihm den krieg zu
beenden und beginn beendete ihn
israel ist ein kleines land das von den
usa abhängig ist es gibt viele solche
fälle für die usa ein vorhaben nicht
befürworten verhindert sie es es ist so
interessant ihnen zuzuhören es gäbe noch
so viel zu fragen wir sind leider am
ende unseres gespräches angelangt
erlauben sie mir eine sehr persönliche
letzte frage
ich weiß dass die burschen drossel sehr
schätzen und deutschland grafl hat
dieses wunderbare buch geschrieben my
life seine autobiografie es beginnt mit
einem prolog und am ende dieses produkt
steht wenn ich die chance bekomme mein
leben noch einmal zulegen dann würde ich
diese chance sehr gerne packen und mein
leben noch einmal leben nur am johns
gilt das gleiche für sie ich bewahre für
das an russell als person und als
philosophen aber ich liebe ihn nicht er
hat manches falsch gemacht wie viele
andere menschen auch ob ich mein leben
nochmals so leben würde ich habe viele
fehler gemacht vieles hätte ich anders
machen sollen fiel es war richtig wie
bei jedem menschen ist das eine
komplizierte geschichte
es war schön dass wir dieses gespräch
führen konnten ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich
[Musik]